well they are stars of the show tonight  congratulations going out to kpvm in  pahrump  a small news operation that caught the  attention of hbo  now the station is the center of a new  hbo original called  small town news we get the product done  we take our time to get it done is  there's a lot of effort that makes it to  get it done  and it's really the commitment behind it  that gets it done  but the quirky things in between that's  when the camera is off you never get to  see  you're going to see i think for small  town news  the joy of it it's going to be so much  different than your average documentary  kpvm is an independently owned local  news station out of pahrump  the series will quote pull back the  curtain on life at a privately owned  television station